we're already laughing here okay a
comedy legend is coming to green valley
ranch resort this saturday check this
out well good looking let me ask you
this
how about if i called you tonight hey
okay i'll take you somewhere we can get
wine for real though
[Applause]
let's go let's go i want to see my
angels hey
[Applause]
first of all first of all i'm laughing
because that just brought back so many
memories of me watching
the legendary and living color
you okay
you're okay he was reliving that i'm
fine
what does that moment bring back for you
uh horror
you're the horror well because
i mean you know
jamie was
took it a little bit far in the actual
take the rehearsal
didn't include him like licking my ear
okay okay you know or or and after that
he pulled the he pulled the tried to
pull the speedos off oh no so it was you
know
it was uh that's the danger of working
with your fellow
immediately you just never know what's
going on you just never know what's
going to happen you know what i mean i
was just like oh come on and then but
then i realized it's tv history it's tv
history
tv so i'll take it a living color was an
iconic show especially for the culture
it just it really set off your career so
many different names yes you know what i
mean jim carrey
jennifer lopez all of us yes yes and
there's another classic there uh
yeah he had money then too and
um
no but but that he's the number one guy
right right right i'm doing that sketch
so it had a different significance at
the time
you know it was like it would like be
the equivalent of me doing something
doing drake or something ah exactly oh
and then the proud family's back i was
just about to go to that because you
know tv history you're still you're
still making tv history the proud family
another cultural icon
you're proud right there tommy davidson
as oscar proud um but you guys had a
reboot we had a reboot tell us about
that where we can find it uh it's on
disney plus it's a reboot from from the
classic crowd family yes yeah i think it
was 20 years ago
all i know is that
yeah yeah yeah my 28 year old was eight
my uh 34 year old was i can't remember
but
you know they were into it and now
they're grown women i just watching them
and then i'm the father in oscar proud
right right so i got to watch them grow
up
and now
your cartoon family and your real family
yeah so it's it's
it's even better we're louder we're
prouder we're reacting to all the things
that are going on in this world today
i'm a part of it um we were really lucky
to be able to record this thing during
the pandemic
we all got together at home right right
did it separately and still were able to
do this but to be able to bring
just to be able to bring the black
experience into every household in the
world
absolutely it's nothing but beneficiary
because the good thing about
uh the good thing about this country
is that actually we don't look at black
and white as different we actually look
at color as cool
and proud family is one of the you know
color's cool and proud family is one of
the things that proved that because zoe
won the dance contest hello all right
well okay speaking of a dance contest
stage you're on stage here in las vegas
on saturday green valley ranch resort
tell people what they can expect how
they get tickets
uh they can expect a lot coming from me
i mean you might even get still
investors alone i mean i don't know you
know what i mean what's wrong with my
house make a stink right think mick you
might get a president obama who's been
around a long time and ain't around no
more or you might get sammy davis jr hey
everyone in vegas yes
come on out and see
watch it hold on this is not a gumball
baby
all right anyway i don't have that much
time
coming out by the way david junior oh
okay hey um good question are we getting
an exclusive right now yes yes we're
asking the universe now right
right if i get an oscar
can you please like tie will to his
belly oh here you go yeah yeah
thank you thank you for joining us it is
an honor to have you here thank you and
you guys can catch him at green valley
ranch
resort saturday april 9 8 p.m
tickets where can they get tickets
uh
i don't know but they can get tickets
okay
there we go
online you'll get tickets online
everybody sammy
tommy davis thank you so much jc i will
send it to you that was amazing